the new haul kind of hallmark commercial
you know
speaking of hallmark you did another
hallmark movie right
yeah love classified
and what's so different about this from
other hallmark movies
hallmark took has been taking some big
steps in the last couple of years with
being more open and more
you know implementing more kind of
diverse storylines into their
their films and their tv shows and
and it's really beautiful to see you
know them
taking steps to to meet the world that
we live in today
um and i was i read this script and i
thought it was in the same way that
shit's creek did the whole you know love
the wine not the label sort of thing
they told a story about love
and letting love surprise you and and
being open to love
in whatever way that comes whether it be
fixing you know some some emotional
damage within your family from the past
or being open to romance for the first
time or being open to dating someone you
never even thought about dating and then
ending up in a beautiful love story
wow well put well put i think you're
maybe describing yourself too
uh maybe maybe hmm